(RAPPING) Hey, Bitsy, I'm from this city,
so please watch how you're talking.
It's home to me.
I love this town.
Let me tell you about Weehawken.
Now, listen.
With all due respect, this town's
better than you would expect.
Never going to meet a more friendly bunch and, oh so
many great spots for lunch.
Weehawken, that's quite the name.
An indigenous word for the Palisades, or kind of
like that, it's complicated.
And by that, I mean appropriated.
Anywho, did I mention the view?
Narrows to the G Dub, It's woo!
It's the best spot in the know who.
Jersey pride, y'all, let me show you.
Because I'm from Weehawken.
All day we jaywalking.
Living high up on the Palisades.
Everybody be flocking to Weehawken.
You know I'm from Weehawken.
Manhattan, keep gawking.
Hit the ferry as it casts away.
Hudson River be rocking in Weehawken.
When we walk, we walking tall.
Weehawken, New Jersey, y'all.
Yes, I'm proud of the pedigree.
Who's from Weehawken, just like me?
Fred Astaire, shake it there.
Smell that fish up in the air.
Daniel Webster goes way back, and that lady that sang
"Love Shack." Pause it there.
I love her hair.
I wonder where she gets it done?
That's one more thing about this town.
We've got such great salons.
Can't help but brag.
And our history's so cool.
We're the home of the Hamilton-Burr duel.
There's a park and a plaque.
It's top notch.
This spot's where Hamilton got shot.
What's good, everybody on the Bluff?
See, that's where I grew up.
I gotta shout out Weehawken High's Young Ladies Euchre
Club. Woo, woo!
00:01:14,150--> 00:01:14,160
Our traffic, slow motion.
Our neighbor, Hoboken.
We use gender-neutral pronouns.
Our population is woke and it smells like the ocean.
And I'm sorry for the self-promotion,
but when I walk out on Hackensack,
I gush out with emotion.
Because I'm from Weehawken.
All day we jaywalking.
Living high up on the Palisades, everybody
be flocking to Weehawken.
You know I'm from Weehawken.
Manhattan, keep gawking.
Hit the ferry as it casts away.
Hudson River be rocking--
[PANTING] in Weehawken.